Professor Ben Polak: So
we're going to do a new topic
today, we're going to talk about
evolution.
We're going to talk about the
connection between evolution and
Game Theory.
Now there's going to be an
extra reading--I've already
emailed you about this--there's
going to be an extra reading on
this for the people who want it.
I'm going to--There's a reading
packet that's available to
anybody who wants it.
I emailed you all,
the website where you can order
that reading packet and figure
out where to pick it up.
It's not compulsory.
You don't have to look at that
reading packet.
It's just that it might help.
In addition,
as with last Wednesday,
since some of the material here
is new,
I have written a handout that
goes with this lecture and that
handout will appear magically
this afternoon on the website.
So if things today are fast,
don't worry there's a handout
that goes with it.
All right, so why look at
evolution in the context of Game
Theory?
There are really two reasons.
The first reason is because of
the influence of Game Theory on
biology.
It turns out that in the last
few decades, there's been an
enormous amount of work done in
biology,
in particular,
looking at animal behavior and
using Game Theory to analyze
that animal behavior.
And just to give you a loose
idea about how this works,
the idea is to relate
strategies with genes,
or at least a phenotype of
those genes, and to relate
payoffs to genetic fitness.
So the idea is that strategies
are related to genes and the
payoffs in the games are related
to genetic fitness.
And the big idea of course,
is that strategies grow if they
do well.
So strategies that do well in
these games grow.
Strategies that do less well
die out.
So we're going to be visiting
that today.
One thing to bear in mind from
the start is that there's an
important difference between
Game Theory as analyzed in
animal behavior and biology,
and Game Theory that we've been
doing so far in the class.
And that is,
that we're going to think of
behaviors, these strategies
played by animals,
not as chosen by reasoning
individuals but rather as being
hardwired.
So if strategies grow it isn't
that some lion or ant has chosen
that strategy.
It's simply that the ant or
lion who has that gene that
corresponds to that strategy
grows and has many children.
So it's important,
this is a new idea for us,
that these strategies are
hardwired.
So it's interesting,
in and of itself,
but there's also an important
influence the other way.
So a second reason for studying
this stuff is that there's been
an enormous influence from
biology or from evolutionary
biology in particular,
back on the social sciences.
This influence the other way
uses evolution largely as a
metaphor.
And you'll find this if you're
a political scientist,
if you're a historian,
if you're an anthropologist,
if you're a sociologist.
Let me give you an example from
Economics, since it's perhaps
closer to home.
So here's an example.
You might imagine some firms in
the marketplace and you could
think of these firms not
necessarily reasoning out what
is the most profitable strategy
for them,
or what is the most
cost-reducing strategy for them.
However, they may just have
rules of thumb to select their
strategies.
However, in a competitive
marketplace, survival of the
fittest firms will lead to us
ending up with a bunch firms who
have low costs and high profits.
That make sense?
So here competition in the
marketplace substitutes for
competition in the jungle,
as it were.
The analog of a gene dying out
is a firm going bankrupt.
So this is the kind of ideas
we're going to explore.
These ideas are going to the
background for today and Monday.
Now before I go on,
I want to put in a couple of
kind of important riders.
So there are two things that I
am not.
The first thing I am not is I'm
not a biologist.
I'm sure there are people in
this room who are biologists who
know a lot more about the
genetic side of this than I do.
So I'm not going to attempt to
teach you biology here,
I'm going to focus on the Game
Theory part.
The second thing I'm not is I'm
not an American citizen.
I worry slightly when we talk
about evolution because I
realize it's very controversial
here, and some of you might be
from places like say Kansas.
And if you are from someplace
like Kansas, then please don't
write to your Senator about
this,
or if they see the movie,
just tell them it was some
other English guy giving the
lecture.
So what we're going to actually
do is we're going to look at a
highly simplified model of
evolution, at least for today.
We might get onto a more
complicated model on Monday,
but today it's going to be very
highly stylized.
So this is going to be our
extremely simplified model.
This simplified model is going
to do tremendous violence to the
biology, but it's really just to
fix some ideas.
So we're going to focus on what
we're going to call within
species competition.
So the lions are competing
against the lions and the ants
are competing against the ants.
The way we're going to think
about this is we're going to
look at symmetric two-player
games.
So we look at very simple
games, they're only going to
involve two players,
and they're going to be
symmetric games,
which means both players have
the same strategies,
both players have the same
payoffs.
The way we're going to think of
is, we're going to imagine that
there's a large population out
there,
each of whom is playing a
particular strategy,
and we're going to assume that
what happens is,
we randomly pick two people
from that population and pair
them up.
So everyone in this large
population will be randomly
paired with someone else,
they'll play the strategy that
they are hardwired to play,
and then we'll see what
happens.
So the idea here is there's a
large population of,
if you like animals,
which are hardwired to play
particular strategies,
and we're going to have random
matching.
The idea here is when we do
lots of these random matching,
we're going to keep track of
the average payoffs.
So what we're going to focus on
are the average payoffs of
particular strategies when
randomly matched in these games.
Again, the underlying idea is
that relatively successful
strategies will grow and
relatively unsuccessful ones
will decline,
I'm not going to write that,
that's obviously the other part
of that.
So relatively successful
strategies are growing and
relatively unsuccessful
strategies are declining.
Now to keep things simple,
I'm not going to do any
dynamics here,
that would take us beyond the
math that you could probably,
that a lot of you can do in the
class.
So we're not going to worry
about dynamics here,
but this is the underlying
dynamic.
The idea is that if a strategy
is successful that strategy will
grow in the population,
if a strategy is unsuccessful
it will decline.
So this isn't horrible violence
to biology yet,
it's the next bit that's the
horrible violence.
So to keep things simple today
we're going to assume that there
is no gene redistribution.
So in principle what we're
looking at is asexual
reproduction,
which is clearly not a good
model but it will do for today.
So you want to think about a
practical example of asexual
reproduction,
think about root vegetables or
judging from our experiments
with the dating game,
we better hope that's true for
Economics majors as well.
Maybe the fact that I'm
focusing on asexual reproduction
will get me off with the guys in
Kansas: maybe I won't lose my
green card after all.
So that's going to be our basic
story, and the basic idea we're
going to use is this.
It's an idea due to a guy
called Maynard Smith in the 70s,
although obviously the big idea
goes back earlier.
So this is the big idea.
Suppose that we imagine that
there's a particular game and
there's these large
populations--think of yourselves
as the large population--and
suppose that the entire
population were all playing the
same strategy,
call it S, so they're all
hardwired to play the same
strategy S.
Suppose now that there's a
mutation, so some small group
start playing some other
strategy, let's call it S'.
What we want to ask is will
that small mutation group,
the S' strategy,
will it thrive or will it die
out?
If it's true that,
for all possible mutations,
all the possible little groups
of mutation of people who are
playing S',
they'll die out,
then we'll say that the
original strategy,
the strategy S,
is evolutionarily stable.
We're going to write that out
more formally later on but
that's just the basic idea,
so let's just say it again.
There's a strategy out there
that everyone's playing,
call it S.
We're going to look at a
mutation, that's S'.
So a small group of people are
going to start playing S'.
They're going to go on being
randomly matched,
everyone's going to be randomly
matched,
and we're going to ask if the
S' group does well,
in which case they'll grow,
or does badly,
in which case they'll shrink
and eventually die out.
If they die out we'll say that
S was evolutionarily stable,
that's true for all possible
mutations.
Just notice when we're randomly
matching them,
one thing to note is since
there's only a small mutation to
start with,
most of the time when they're
randomly matched,
they're going to match against
somebody who's still playing S.
Occasionally they're going to
meet one of the other mutants,
but most of the time we're
going to have to worry about how
the mutants do against the
incumbent population.
That was too abstract to really
get one's head around,
so let's try and do an example.
So let's remove our motivation
and get down to actually doing
some work.
So we're going to start with a
very simple example that you'll
all recognize.
Here's a game,
it's a two-by-two game,
and the payoffs are as follows,
(2,2), (0,3),
(3,0) and (1,1).
We'll call these strategies
cooperate or defect:
C for cooperate,
D for defect.
You'll all recognize
immediately that this game is
what?
This is Prisoners' Dilemma.
So we're going to start by
imagining these animals playing
Prisoner's Dilemma.
And to put it into context,
imagine that these are a group
of lions--and again leave aside
the fact that it's asexual
reproduction for a
second--imagine these are a
group of lions.
And cooperating means
cooperating on the hunt,
it means using a lot of energy
going after--as you cooperate in
a group while hunting.
And defecting here would mean
not working hard on the hunt and
letting the other lions catch
the antelope or whatever,
and then just sharing in the
spoils: so "free riding"
basically.
Or another example,
think about ants with an ant
nest, imagine this ant nest has
been attacked by I don't know
what, some other creature.
You could imagine that
cooperating is joining in,
in defending the nest,
at the risk of being hurt and
defecting is running away.
We all know in this game
roughly how to analyze it.
I'm not going to go over that
now.
I want to ask a different
question today.
I want to ask in this model of
asexual reproduction is
cooperation evolutionarily
stable?
So to try and illustrate that,
let's just think about this
game being played for real out
there.
So what I'm going to do is
we're going to start off by
imagining that you are all,
I don't know,
ants, lions,
what do you want to be?
Ants I think.
So you're, from up here you
look like ants.
You're all ants and all of you
have been hardwired to play the
strategy C.
So life's going on fine and
let's do some random matching
here, so suppose that we
randomly match this ant,
so stand up a second,
so this ant gets randomly
matched with this ant,
so they now play this
Prisoner's Dilemma against one
another,
but both of them have been
hardwired to cooperate,
so they both cooperate,
is that right?
So this ant whose name is?
Student: Lenore.
Professor Ben Polak:
Lenore the ant cooperates and-
Student: Woo.
Professor Ben Polak: -
and Woo the ant cooperates.
So since they both cooperate
there, we can look at what their
payoff is, their payoff is
cooperate against cooperate,
so they get 2,
so that's pretty good,
so they're doing pretty well in
terms of genetic fitness and
suddenly there are two ants,
right?
So this ant produces another
ant, someone without a computer,
and this ant produces another
ant,
so they're doing fine and the
whole population is matching
against other cooperative ants,
and more ants are being
produced and everything is fine
and dandy, everything looks
good.
Sit down a second.
Now imagine that there's a
mutation, a small mutation,
and this small mutation
involves a group of rather nasty
uncooperative ants,
so a scary mutation.
So here's our scary mutation.
Let's use the T.A.'s.
So the T.A.'s are my scary
mutations, so all of the T.A.'s
here are the scary mutations,
there's another one over there.
So there's a bunch,
everyone else is still playing
cooperate, there's this vast
number of cooperative ants,
but now there's these small
number of ants with this
mutation that says don't
cooperate,
play D.
So let's see what happens with
random matching.
So a lot of these cooperative
ants are still matching with
each other and doing fine,
but that's not the point.
What we're worried about is
what's going to happen to the
mutants?
So let's pick our
representative nasty mutant,
so that's going to be Rahul,
so Rahul is our scary mutant
and let's go back and randomly
match him against one of our
incumbent ants,
our nice, cooperative ants,
so let's pick this one.
So it just happens that he's
randomly matched with this
cooperative ant,
and this cooperative ant,
whose name is?
Student: Nick.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nick is hardwired since he's a
regular ant he's hardwired to
play cooperate,
so he's going to play
cooperate.
Say cooperate,
I should have brought a mic but
never mind, and meanwhile do you
have a mic handy,
thank you.
All right, so he says cooperate
but unfortunately he's been
matched against the nasty
uncooperative ant.
It's not that he's nasty he's
just been hardwired to say?
Student: Not cooperate.
Professor Ben Polak: Not
cooperate, to say defect.
So what's going to happen now?
So unfortunately for Nick he,
the cooperative ant,
was matched against a not very
nice ant,
he was playing C and Rahul was
playing D, so Nick's payoff is
0, so we went from one Nick to
being no Nick,
he got wiped out.
Rahul meanwhile,
he got a payoff of what?
What was Rahul's payoff?
Rahul's payoff is 3,
so suddenly there's not just
Rahul but there's,
the mutation is growing.
Now, we go on matching,
each period some of you are
going to be matched against
other cooperative ants and
you're going to be doing fine,
but every now and then,
actually increasingly often,
you're going to be matched
against one of our mutants and
those mutants are going to grow,
those mutants are going to go
on growing.
Now it's true that every now
and then a mutant's going to
meet another mutant,
is that right?
But we don't have to worry
about that, all we have to worry
about is, are they going to die
out early on?
It's going to be very rare for
them to meet another mutant,
at least early on.
So the strategy cooperate is
evolutionarily stable if this
small mutation,
here's our small mutation,
disappears and doesn't turn
into a bigger mutation.
Of course in this case,
as we just saw,
the mutation didn't die out,
it actually grew.
So to be formal about this,
let me be careful,
for the strategy cooperate to
be evolutionary stable it needs
to be the case that the mutation
actually dies out on average,
and here far from dying out,
it grew.
We now have lots of these nasty
T.A.'s.
People understand?
All right, so let's just,
thanks.
So let's just try and do that a
little bit more formally on the
board.
That was the basic idea,
and the graphics of the idea,
but let's look at it a little
bit more formally.
So we basically have
cooperative ants and a few
mutant defecter ants out there,
so mutant not-cooperative ants,
and what we want to keep track
of, are their average payoffs in
random matches.
So the incumbent ant,
the cooperative ants,
they're playing,
we're interested in their
payoff and they're playing a
population that's mixed.
Almost everybody in the
population is cooperative,
so let's say 1 - ε
of the people they're playing
against (where ε
is a small number,
a very small number) are also
cooperative, but every now and
then, like our poor friend Nick,
they're going to come across a
nasty mutant,
they're going to come across
Rahul.
So what's their payoff going to
be on average,
their average payoff?
So 1 - ε
of the time,
we can actually think of this
mix here, so it's 1 - ε
and ε.
1 - ε of the time they're
going to meet another
cooperative ant and get a payoff
of 2,
but ε of the time they're
going to meet Rahul and get a
payoff of 0.
Is that correct?
So that's their average payoff.
Now how about the mutants'
payoffs?
So the mutants,
there aren't many of them
around, but they are also
playing against the same mixed
population,
1 - ε of the time they're
going to be matched against a
cooperative ant and ε
of the time the two mutants,
the two T.A.'s are going to
playoff against each other.
Let's have a look at what their
payoff is.
So their payoff is 1 - ε,
they get a payoff of 3,
that's what we saw when Rahul
met Nick and the other ε
of the time,
Rahul meets Jake or somebody
and has to make do with a payoff
of 1.
But if we keep track of this,
what do we have?
This equals 2(1--ε) and
this equals 3(1--ε) +
ε.
Is that right?
Clearly, I hope this is clear,
the payoff to the mutant is
bigger.
Everyone happy with that?
The payoff to the mutant is
bigger which means the mutation
is not going to die out.
In fact it's going to grow.
Mutation's not going to die out.
So we can conclude that C is
not evolutionarily stable.
I'm going to start using ES for
evolutionarily stable.
So in this particular game
cooperation is not ES.
So we might ask what is ES in
this game?
Well that's not going to be
hard to figure it out,
since there is only one choice.
I claim that D is going to be
ES, but let's just prove it.
So is it going to be the case
that these mutants will
eventually take over the whole
population and everyone will end
up looking like a T.A.
and being uncooperative?
So they're busily asexually
reproducing all the time,
they get bigger and bigger,
and isn't it in fact the case
that once they've conquered
everything that they're ES?
So is defect ES in this game?
To figure that out we have to
do exactly the reverse
experiment.
So the experiment now is
imagine everyone in the
population, all of you guys,
all of the students in the room
are nasty non-cooperative
defecting ants.
You're going along and most of
the time you're meeting,
your meeting each other all the
time for now and you're getting
a payoff of 1.
And now there's a mutation,
but this time the mutation
isn't the scary non-cooperative
mutation that we saw before with
Rahul,
it's going to be Myrto over
there.
And Myrto is a nice mutation
who cooperates.
So Myrto's our nice,
cooperative mutation.
Let me just get the camera to
pan on poor little Myrto.
So there is poor little Myrto
who is the only cooperative
mutation in the room.
Wave, there we go okay, right.
What's going to happen to our
cooperative mutation?
So most of the time you
non-cooperative people are
matching up against each other.
We're going to figure out what
your payoff is.
So that the uncooperative
incumbents, they're playing a
population that is 1 - ε
non-cooperative and ε
of the time they meet Myrto.
So what's their average payoffs?
Let's be careful,
let's switch things around up
here just to make sure we can
see what happened.
So switching things around on
our chart up here,
we're now looking at the case
where there's 1 - ε
non-cooperators and ε
cooperators.
So you guys,
you non-cooperative ants are
most of the time meeting each
other, and when you meet each
other you're getting a payoff of
1.
So 1 - ε
of the time you're getting a
payoff of 1, but ε
of the time you're doing great
because you're meeting Myrto,
and unfortunately you're
beating up on Myrto.
How is she doing?
Well she's a cooperator and 1 -
ε of the time she's meeting
you guys and ε
of the time she meets another
nice cooperative ant like Jake.
So her payoff is 1 - ε
of the time she gets nothing
and ε of the time she does
pretty well and gets 2,
but it's only ε
of the time.
Is that right?
So far, so good.
So what's going to happen to
this mutation?
Well the incumbent population,
their average payoff comes down
to being 1 - ε
+ 3ε and Myrto's payoff,
the mutant ends up being
2ε.
So unfortunately,
these nasty ants are thriving
and Myrto gets wiped out,
so she can sit down again.
So what have we shown here?
We've shown that defect,
not cooperate,
is evolutionarily stable in
this game.
Any mutation,
there's only one possible
mutation, any mutation gets
wiped out.
Think about these two different
models here.
The first, well not different
models but different metaphors,
so we started out with this
population of relatively nice
people and we had a nasty
mutation,
so think of the movie Alien,
actually don't because it's a
horrible movie,
but all right and if you
remember that horrible movie,
Alien or Species,
think of the movie Species,
an even worse movie.
Think of the movie Species.
That was Rahul and he grew
albeit asexually,
very rapidly.
That's a pretty scary movie,
right?
Conversely, when we had this
population of nasty people and
we tried to have a nice little
invasion of a nice mutant,
so think of the movie ET,
unfortunately,
ET got squished,
that's the two extremes.
So what is the lesson that we
can actually draw from this?
So there's a lesson here and
the lesson--I guess there's
going to be two lessons here but
let's start with one.
The first lesson here is
that,--well let's just put it on
the board first of all.
Nature, the outcome of
evolution, nature,
can suck.
So again we could use a more
formal term but this is an
important lesson.
There's a tendency for some
people to think that if
something arises as a
consequence of evolution,
if something is natural,
if something is in nature,
it must therefore be good in
some moral way,
efficient or something.
What we're seeing here is in
this game the consequence of
nature is a horrible
consequence.
For those people who doubt that
nature can be pretty unpleasant
have a look at yesterday's
science page of The New York
Times,
and read the piece about how
the baboons basically kill the
baby baboons.
The biggest cause of death
among baby baboons is
infanticide.
This is ES it turns out and
they explain why in The Times.
It isn't pleasant.
So nature can suck,
nature can be pretty
inefficient.
Now, this raises a question in
this particular game because
look at the examples we started
with.
We started with lions who are
thinking about--or not thinking
about, sorry,
they weren't thinking
about--they were hardwired to go
after antelope and either
cooperate or not.
And we talked about ants who
are hardwired to defend the nest
or not.
We all know from watching
endless nature shows as children
on TV that actually lions do
cooperate when they go after
antelope,
and actually ants do defend the
nest when it's invaded by a
spider or something.
Is that right?
Looking for some nodding,
is that right?
Yeah okay, good.
So what happened?
What's wrong with our model
here?
We've argued here that,
in this model,
nature's going to produce this
non-cooperative behavior.
We know there are examples of
cooperation in nature,
what's going on?
What are we missing?
Can I get a mike in here.
It's here.
Let me do it.
I'll do it.
Yeah, so what's going on?
Student: Different
communities might compete
against each other,
so one community that doesn't
have any of these mutations and
stays cooperative might succeed,
so communities in general don't
have as many mutations.
Professor Ben Polak:
Okay, so that's an interesting
idea.
So part of this is because
we're focusing on within species
competition rather than the
cross-species competition.
That turned out to be a
complicated idea and large
literature on it and it's
actually a little difficult.
I was looking for,
but it's a good suggestion,
I was looking for something
simpler actually,
let me come back here.
Student: Do these
species have ways to detect
cheaters and punish them?
Professor Ben Polak:
Okay, that might be a
possibility and certainly there
is some evidence of that but not
much.
Again, we're looking at pretty
high primates by the time you
get to that.
Something simpler,
something you should all have
on your mind all the time if
you're normal teenagers.
Student: The payoffs
could change as the proportion
of cheaters increases,
so you're not going to get the
payoff of 3 if everyone's
cheating.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, but okay,
it's true that you're going to
get a different expected payoff,
but that isn't the payoff of
the game.
I'm looking for something
really simple that,
let me repeat,
I'm guessing is on all of your
minds as teenagers.
Let's see if that hint's going
to get the right answer.
Yeah.
Student: Answer,
not asexual.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, the assumption that's
really driving this here is the
assumption of asexual
reproduction.
Sexual reproduction with gene
exchange is going to make a
difference.
Why?
I don't want to delve too much
into the biology here,
but the main why is,
what matters is the survival of
the gene,
not survival of the individual
ant or individual lion.
So if you have sexual
reproduction you get gene
redistribution among children
and cousins to a less extent,
so provided the other ants in
the nest are closely enough
genetically related to you,
and provided the lions are
close enough related to you,
then it may turn out to be,
it may turn out that you will
cooperate, and that in fact,
does change the payoffs of the
game.
It doesn't change the payoffs
for the individual lion or ant,
it changes the payoffs for the
gene.
Now if we have time we'll come
back and look at that on Monday,
and even if we don't have time,
in the reading I've left for
you in the reading packet,
it goes into that in some
detail.
It's a much more complicated
model but that's what we're
going to get,
for the most part that's where
we're going to get cooperation
from rather than from the other
points that people made.
So sex can make a difference
here, but we're going to stick
with asexual reproduction
because it's easier to analyze
and stick with it for the
minute.
And we've learned,
the second lesson we've learned
here, I'm going to generalize
from this lesson,
we learned that a strategy that
was strictly dominated was not
evolutionarily stable.
I've only shown an example here
but we'll extend from the
example.
So if a strategy is strictly
dominated, and of course
cooperate is strictly dominated
here,
then it is not evolutionarily
stable, at least in this simple
game of just asexual
reproduction.
Even though I haven't proved
this here, the idea is exactly
the idea of this example,
so let's just try and talk it
through.
Suppose a strategy was strictly
dominated, how do we know,
how can we see that it will not
be evolutionarily stable?
Somebody?
Where are my pre-med majors?
Where are my pre-med people?
They're all hiding now.
I know you're out there because
I've seen your forms,
but never mind.
Why is this dominated strategy
not evolutionarily stable?
Student: The strategy
that dominates it will be a
successful mutation.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so the strategy that
dominates, the strategy that
does the domination of this
strictly dominated strategy
would be a successful mutation.
If it enters it does well,
not just against this strategy
but against any mix involving
itself and this strategy.
So the strictly dominator
strategy will invade.
So we can't have strictly
dominated strategies surviving
in evolution.
Let's do another example and
we'll see if we can learn some
more.
So this is going to be a
slightly more complicated
example.
Let's have a three-by-three
game, so here's our
three-by-three game and we'll
just label the strategies A,
B, C and A, B,
C and once again we're going to
focus on symmetric games,
so this game will be symmetric:
2,
2,0, 0,0, 0,0,
0, lots of zeros in this,
1,1, 0,0,1,1,0,0.
So this is a symmetric game.
We'll look at this game a
little bit, I don't want to look
at all of it,
I want to ask the question is
strategy C evolutionarily
stable?
Let's go back to our experiment.
What does it involve?
Imagine everyone in the room is
hardwired to play C,
could that population be
invaded by a mutation?
So what do we think?
Is C evolutionarily stable?
Who thinks it is stable?
Who thinks it's not stable?
So most of you think it's not
stable so you must have some
idea why.
Why do we think it's not stable?
Let me just try and cold call a
little bit.
Anybody?
Let me sample somebody.
If it's not stable it must be
it's going to get invaded,
so who's going to invade it?
Can we try this gentleman here,
have a guess who's going to
invade it?
Student: Strategy B.
Professor Ben Polak:
Strategy B, okay that's correct.
Your name is?
Student: Greg.
Professor Ben Polak: So
Greg is saying strategy B might
invade here, let's have a look,
let's see what happens.
So suppose there's an invasion
of B, so again the T.A.'s are
playing B, everyone else is
playing C, and let's see how
these incumbent genes do.
So C is playing against 1 -
ε of the population who are
playing C and ε
who are playing B and its
average payoff?
Well 1 - ε
of the time it'll be matched
against essentially itself and
get a payoff of 0,
but ε of the time it will
be matched against a B and get a
payoff of 1.
Everyone agree with that?
So 1 - ε
of the time it meets itself and
gets nothing,
ε of the time it gets
lucky and it meets a T.A.
and gets a payoff of 1.
How about those B invaders,
the T.A.'s in the class.
So 1 - ε
of the time they're going to
meet C's and ε
meet B's and 1 - ε
of the time therefore,
the B is meeting a C and
getting a payoff of 1,
so 1 - ε
of the time the T.A.
is meeting one of you.
And ε of the time the T.A.
is meeting another T.A.,
playing B against B,
and getting 0.
So this works out as ε
and this works out as 1 -
ε.
But notice that if ε
is small, if there were just a
small number of these mutations,
1 - ε is bigger than
ε.
Is that right?
So that means that this
mutation will not die out,
it'll probably go on,
we can actually say a bit more,
it'll probably go on growing
until it's roughly half the
population.
But, in particular,
it won't die out.
Since it won't die out,
since the mutation doesn't die
out, we can conclude that C is
not evolutionarily stable.
Everyone okay with that idea?
Now this idea,
this example is a little bit
more complicated than the
previous example,
because it turns out that the
invading mutant population,
the population B is itself not
evolutionarily stable.
Everyone see that?
C wasn't evolutionarily stable
because it got invaded by B.
Who's going to invade B?
C is going to invade B,
turns out everything is exactly
symmetric here.
So even though we're arguing
that C is not evolutionarily
stable because it's invaded by
B,
it doesn't have to be the case
that the successful mutant is
itself evolutionarily stable.
So in this particular example
the invader, namely B,
is itself not evolutionarily
stable.
Nevertheless,
it doesn't die out but it
invades the population of C's.
But there's a second
observation I want to draw off
this one, hoping there's a bit
of chalk here,
not finding it,
there's a second observation I
want to draw here,
what do we observe?
What else is true about both C
and B?
So what's true about everyone
playing C or everyone playing B?
What else?
Just going back to what we've
learned in the course so far,
what do we think about everyone
playing C?
So if we had everyone playing C
we'd be looking at an object
like this (C,C) and we might ask
the question is (C,C) what?
Is it a Nash Equilibrium?
Is (C,C) a Nash Equilibrium?
Here we asked was it
evolutionarily stable,
we found it wasn't.
Let's ask a different question,
and forget evolution for a
second.
Is (C,C) a Nash Equilibrium?
Well that's a question you all
should be able to answer for the
mid-term so somebody tell me the
answer.
It's not a Nash Equilibrium,
how do we know it's not a Nash
Equilibrium?
What do we have to do to show
it's not a Nash Equilibrium?
We have to show that there's a
profitable deviation,
right.
So what's the,
shout it out,
what's the profitable deviation
here?
Profitable deviation is B.
It's not no because B is a
strictly profitable deviation.
Notice that the thing that was
a strictly profitable deviation
was the same thing that would
have invaded the population of
C's in the context of our ant's
nest and the context of this
classroom being an ant's nest
and looking at evolution.
Is that right?
So what have we just learned
here?
Well this idea turns out to be
general.
The idea is if a strategy S,
perhaps I should make this a
lesson, if a strategy S is not
Nash,
so in other words (S,S) is not
a Nash Equilibrium,
then S is not evolutionarily
stable.
If S is not Nash,
then S is not evolutionarily
stable.
Now with a little bit of logic,
can we flip that around and we
will say, what that actually
tells us is,
it's equivalent to saying,
if S is evolutionarily stable
then (S,S) is a Nash
Equilibrium,
that's the equivalent way of
saying that.
So what's the idea here?
Let's look at the first line
rather than the second line,
because it's pretty easy to
understand.
The idea here is,
if a strategy is not Nash,
what that means is,
is there's some other strategy
that would be a strictly
profitable deviation and that's
enough to tell us that S cannot
be evolutionarily stable.
Why?
Because take that same strategy
that was a strictly profitable
deviation, B in this case,
and that strategy can be
thought of as the mutation
that's going to invade the
strategy we started from.
Everyone see that?
Say it once more.
Suppose a strategy isn't,
suppose strategy (S,S) is not a
Nash Equilibrium.
What that means is some other
strategy S' say that is a
strictly profitable deviation.
Now think about strictly
profitable deviation S' as a
mutant invasion,
so now Rahul is playing,
is hardwired to play S'.
Since it was strictly
profitable it's going to be,
since it was strictly
profitable as a deviation,
it's going to be successful as
an invader.
So again I haven't formally
proved it, but that's exactly
how the proof would run.
So let's pause for a second and
just see where we are.
What we've managed to show is
there's a connection here
between dominance and
evolutionarily stable.
We've said if a strategy is not
dominated it cannot be
evolutionarily stable.
We've also begun to show a
connection between Nash
Equilibrium and evolutionary
stability.
So two of the ideas we've
developed over the last six
weeks are re-emerging in this
completely other context of
animal behavior.
The idea of dominance and the
idea of Nash,
and so far how far have we got?
We've said that if something's
going to be evolutionarily
stable it better be the case
that it's also Nash.
That raises I think a natural
question which is,
is the opposite true?
It would be really pretty great
if it were true the other way
around.
If I could show that if a
strategy was Nash then it would
necessarily also be ES.
That would be pretty cool,
right?
This idea we've spent a lot of
time developing in the class
turns out to be the key idea.
Unfortunately,
life isn't quite so neat.
Let's see why.
So what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to show you an
example and what our example's
going to illustrate is we can
find Nash strategies that are
not evolutionarily stable,
and the example is
embarrassingly simple.
Here's a game,
it's a two player,
two strategy game and the
payoffs are (1,1),
(0,0), (0,0),
(0,0).
This is kind of an
embarrassingly simple game.
What are the Nash Equilibria in
this game?
Well let's go through slowly.
If Player row is playing A,
then column's best response is
to pick A and if player row is
playing B,
then column's best response is
either to play A or B.
If column is playing A,
then row's best response is to
choose A.
If column is playing B,
then row's best response is
either A or B.
So this is the kind of exercise
that is almost second nature for
you guys now.
So we can conclude by looking
where the Nash,
where these best responses
coincide, that the Nash
Equilibria here are (A,A) and
(B,B).
Everyone happy with that?
You should be looking like yeah
this is easy,
right?
So all right,
but let's look at this second
Nash Equilibrium.
The (B,B) Nash Equilibrium,
the one that's down here.
Is B evolutionarily stable?
Well again let's think about
it, let's just think through the
exercise.
Suppose the entire class were
playing B.
Wake up the guy in the middle
and tell him he's playing B too.
The whole class is playing B
and suppose there's an invasion.
What could the invasion be?
The invasion better be an
invasion of A's.
What's going to be the expected
payoff or the average payoff of
the incumbents,
of all of you in the class who
are playing B?
Well, without doing it too
laboriously, 1 - ε
of the time you're going to
meet another student in which
case your payoff,
in which case you'll be playing
B against B and your payoff will
0 and ε of the time you're
going to meet a T.A.
and these T.A.'s are playing A,
but again, you'll get 0,
so your average payoff will be
what?
0, your payoff will be 0.
So if you're an incumbent and
you, against this mix,
your payoff will be 0.
And if you're an invader?
So how is Rahul doing this time?
Rahul's playing A.
1 - ε of the time this A
is playing against B,
so 1 - ε
of the time he's playing
against a B.
So 1 - ε
of the time Rahul meets a
student and gets a payoff of 0.
But ε of the time Rahul
hits it lucky and Rahul meets
another T.A.,
Rahul meets Jake and when he
meets Jake his payoff is 1.
Is that correct?
So his total average payoff is
ε, which is bigger than 0,
so indeed, it turns out that
Rahul's gene is going to grow,
the B's are going to shrink.
(B,B) was Nash but it's not
evolutionarily stable,
it can be invaded.
Everyone see that?
Everyone see how that invasion
worked?
So the key to that invasion was
when Rahul met another incumbent
student he did no better than
the students did against
students.
But on those rare occasions
when Rahul met another T.A.
he made hay--or not hay,
it's asexual reproduction--he
got a payoff of 1.
Those rare occasions were
enough to make Rahul grow and
thrive, whereas the B's
relatively speaking,
shrank.
Everyone happy with that?
Okay, so what we have here is
an example of something that is
Nash but is not evolutionarily
stable.
Can anyone say what's special
about this example?
How did I rig this example?
There's something really kind
of knife edged and rigged about
this example.
What's rigged about this
example?
Anybody?
I don't want to cold call on
this.
No takers, everyone's kind of
in that pre-midterm scared mode.
This guy is rescuing,
this guy is saving the class
today.
Someone else has to get in.
What's your name again,
I forgot your name?
Student: Steven.
Professor Ben Polak: So
Steven is saving the rest of
you, but go ahead Steven.
Student: B is only a
weak best response to anything.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so what's true about this
example is that although B is a
best response against B,
it only is so weakly.
Is that right?
It's only so weakly.
If, in fact,
we got rid of Nash Equilibria
that relied only on weak best
responses, then we wouldn't be
able to produce this example.
So, in particular,
if we looked at Nash
Equilibria, where the Nash
strategy was strictly a best
response,
it was strictly better than
playing any other pure strategy,
those cases would be
evolutionarily stable.
Anybody remember what we call
Nash Equilibria where the Nash
strategy is a strict best
response?
We call them strict Nash,
so it is in fact true,
is if (S,S) is a strict Nash
Equilibrium,
by which I mean S is a strict
best response to S,
then S is a Nash
equilibrium--sorry,
S is evolutionarily stable.
Okay, so we've been pretty,
we've been only semi-formal so
far.
I haven't really put up a
formal definition,
and what I've been groping
towards slowly is a connection
between an idea growing out of
biology,
namely evolutionarily stable,
and an idea growing out of
Economics and Mathematics,
namely Nash Equilibrium.
What I want to do now is I
wanted to show you formally how
are these connected.
I'm not going to prove this
part of the class,
because a proof is a bit
lengthy,
but I will include a proof on
the handout that's going to be
available this afternoon.
I'm just going to argue it for
now.
Here we go, there's some chalk.
So what I want to do first is I
want to write down a formal
definition of evolutionary
stability.
It's a definition that comes
out of biology and it's a little
bit of a, you're going to see
it's a little bit of a mouthful
this definition.
So for those people who are a
little bit sleepy,
you need to wake up a little
bit, because it's going to be a
little bit of a difficult
definition.
But this is the definition that
came out of biology.
This is a formal definition.
It comes out of biology,
and in particular,
it's due to a guy called
Maynard Smith who wrote this in
1972.
So obviously the earlier idea
is due to Darwin,
but this formal idea is due to
Maynard Smith.
So here's our formal definition.
So in a symmetric two player
game--so everything we've been
looking at so far --,
the pure strategy S--let's call
it Ŝ,--let's give it a name
--, is evolutionarily stable
--and again I'll use ES for
that,
but let me be a little bit
nerdy here.
I'm going to say in pure
strategies: it's evolutionarily
stable in pure strategies--and
I'm putting this in because
we're going to come back on
Monday and consider mixed
strategies.
So it's evolutionarily stable
in pure strategies if,
and just leave a little bit of
a space here,
because I'm going to need a
little bit of space between
these next two lines,
leave a little space here.
So here's our big mouthful,
what we need is 1 - ε
of the payoff of playing Ŝ
against Ŝ
plus ε of the payoff of
playing Ŝ
against S' has to be strictly
bigger than 1 - ε
of the payoff of playing S'
against Ŝ
plus ε of the payoff of
playing S' against itself.
This has to be true for all
possible deviations S',
but we also,
this is why we need the extra
line,
and for all mutation sizes
ε less than some
ε-bar.
This is where I need to go back
and just be a bit more careful,
so I'm going to write on this
extra line, there exists an
ε-bar.
That's why I left the extra
line there.
So this looks like very nerdy
things.
Let's talk our way through it.
What's it saying?
It's saying that Ŝ
is evolutionarily stable if
against all possible mutations,
so all possible versions of
Rahul S', the payoff of Ŝ
against the subsequently mixed
population is bigger than the
payoff of S' against the
subsequently mixed population.
Let's just see why that is so.
So this on the left is the
payoff of Ŝ
against a population in which 1
- ε of the population like
it is playing Ŝ
and ε of the population is
like Rahul,
because 1 - ε
of the time it meets something
like itself, and ε
of the time it meets a T.A.
Conversely, on the right hand
side, we have the payoff to the
mutation.
The payoff to the mutation is 1
- ε of the time the T.A.
meets a student and gets the
payoff of S' against Ŝ,
ε of the time the T.A.
meets itself and gets a payoff
of S' against S',
and we have this inequality we
had before,
that says the mutation invader
has to do worse so it dies out.
So the nasty bit of this
definition, the part that's a
little bit--it takes a while to
get your head around--is this
qualifier about the size of
mutations.
And all it's saying,
ignore the math of it,
all it's saying is this better
be true for all small mutations.
You could think of that saying,
this has to be true for all
small mutations.
So this definition from biology
is exactly, it exactly mimics
the argument which we went
through several times now,
both using the class and using
the board and figuring out
average payoffs.
This is an ugly definition.
Everyone agree this is kind of
ugly?
So now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to give you an
entirely different definition.
It's also going to be ugly but
a little bit less ugly.
So think of that as Definition
1, and it came from biology,
it came from this paper in
1972.
I think it was in Nature by
Maynard Smith and co-authors.
Think of this other definition,
that's coming out of Economics.
So Definition 2,
a strategy Ŝ--I should
have had the same qualifier,
in a symmetric two player
game--same thing to start off
with--a strategy Ŝ
is ES in pure strategies--so
same as we had before if two
things.
Thing number one,
let's call it A,
if (Ŝ, Ŝ) is a Nash
Equilibrium--is a symmetric
obviously--is a symmetric Nash
Equilibrium of the game.
We're not done yet.
Let me just write down what it
means to be a symmetric Nash
Equilibrium of the game,
what does that mean?
That means i.e.,
the payoff of Ŝ
against Ŝ
must be at least as big as the
payoff of S' against Ŝ
for all S'.
That's just a standard thing
we've seen it many,
many times, it says Ŝ
is a best response against
Ŝ.
We're not quite done yet.
And B: what else do we need?
We need, if this weak
inequality I wrote above is
actually an equality,
if the payoff of Ŝ
against itself is actually
equal to the payoff of S'
against Ŝ,
then the payoff of Ŝ
against S' must be bigger than
the payoff of S' against itself.
So this is still a bit of a
mouthful, but I claim it's going
to end up being--it ends up
being a little simpler to think
about.
So let's see what it says
again, it says Ŝ
is evolutionarily stable if
it's a Nash Equilibrium,
that's basically this and if
it's only a weak Nash
Equilibrium--there's a tie --,
then it better beat up on the
mutant.
It better beat up on the mutant
when it meets the mutant.
I'm going to try and give you
an intuition as to why this is
true in a minute,
but first I want to tell you
why you should care about this.
So without getting too
religious, I want to tell you
why I think this is an exciting
result.
Why am I dragging you through
more algebra than usual?
So I'm going to give you two
reasons why this is an important
result.
The first is,
it's going to turn out that
when we analyze games it's very
easy to check Definition 2.
It's going to turn out it's
very easy to check Definition 2.
It's really rather a pain to
check Definition 1.
Why?
Because you got to keep track
of these ε
's and so on,
but the fact that Definition 2
is equivalent to Definition
1--did I say that?
That's the point.
The fact that Definition 1 and
2 are equivalent--so 1 is
equivalent to 2--the fact that
these definitions are equivalent
means we only have to check the
second definition and that's
easy.
So when biologists are setting
up experiments involving wasps
or ants, or lions,
or chimpanzees,
provided they can check this in
the game they're done,
and that turns out to be easy.
And we'll see that on Monday.
That's the sort of instrumental
reason.
Now I want to give you the
"religious" reason why you
should care about this.
So let me just try--and I often
find that this appeals to like a
third of the students and the
other two-thirds of the students
think I'm completely bonkers at
this point.
So that's fine,
you can think I'm bonkers,
that's fine.
For the third of you who are
nerdy like me,
I want you to just see the
appeal of this.
Here we have two ideas.
One idea arises out of biology.
I say it rose from Maynard
Smith but it really comes from
Darwin.
So it's a nineteenth century
idea in biology.
It's probably the most
important idea in biology in the
nineteenth century.
It may be the most important
idea in biology for 200 years.
Is that a fair judgment?
The notion of evolutionary
stability.
The other idea comes out of
Economics.
It's looking at Nash Equilibria
and strict Nash Equilibria and
so on.
Up there we've got biology;
down here we have Economics.
This is an idea that emerged in
Economics in the twentieth
century in the 1950s,
so roughly 80 years after
Darwin.
This is a big idea in
Economics, this is a big idea in
biology.
So what appeals to me because
I'm kind of a nerdy kind of guy
is I think it's kind of
wonderful that those two ideas
are almost the same.
I think it's a beautiful thing
that those two ideas are kind of
the same thing.
But now you are looking at me
and thinking I'm bonkers.
So let me push it harder.
So think back to the,
think about great intellectual
coincidences of earlier periods.
Think about the seventeenth
century.
In the seventeenth century
people figured out that the
mechanical laws that governed
the rotation of the planets were
at least approximately the same
as those that governed a clock.
The basic laws of Newtonian
Physics were the same,
and they thought this was a
wonderful thing.
They have these completely
different areas of intellectual
pursuit and they turned out to
be the same.
In the scientific revolution,
it turned out they were the
same.
For those people who chose to
continue believing in God at
that point, they thought of God
now as being what?
As being a heavenly clock maker.
It was a wonderful moment.
So here, in our own time,
or perhaps just before it,
we see a similar thing.
Here we see one of the most
important ideas in science
coinciding with one of the most
important ideas in Economics.
Where does this lead us?
Well now I guess,
I mean the bad news is this may
make a lot of people doubt the
existence of God I guess.
[That's going to get me in
trouble, I didn't say that.]
But at least if you did go on
believing in God,
you're going to have to believe
God's an economist,
that's a pretty good thing.
So that's my little religious
piece on this.
All right, now I want to spend
the last ten minutes,
having told you this wonderful
thing,
trying to convince you that
it's true, and again,
there's a proof on the handout
that you can read on the web.
I just want to give you an idea
of why it's true.
Okay, so here we go.
What I want to convince you of
is that this definition,
this kind of Game Theory
definition, this Econ definition
implies the one above.
The one above we kind of
already argued several times
today, corresponds to the notion
of evolutionarily stability.
We talked about it several
times.
We wrote down these kind of
equations several times.
So I want to convince you that
this one implies that one.
So what do I have to convince
you?
Let's imagine,
let's fix, there's no way of
getting you to see that one
without--no, never mind,
it was a bad idea.
The embarrassment of playing
with heavy boards here.
Alright let's try and shift
this one up.
If you ever think of asking
your dean for some new
technology for Yale,
we might think about having
some slightly lighter
blackboards.
Just for the evolutionary
stability of the average
weakling economist.
So what I'm going to do is
let's fix a strategy Ŝ
and suppose (Ŝ,Ŝ) is
in fact Nash.
What I want to convince you of
is that Ŝ
is going to be evolutionarily
stable.
So I claim there's two
possibilities,
there are two cases.
The two cases are either it's
the case that Ŝ
against Ŝ
does strictly better than
Ŝ against S' for all S'.
So let's just be careful,
since we know its Nash,
we already know that the payoff
of Ŝ against itself is at
least weakly better than any
possible deviation,
that's what it means to be Nash.
So everyone agree with that?
We know that Ŝ
is a best response to Ŝ,
so it must be weakly better
than any possible deviation.
So let's take the first case,
where actually it's strictly
better, and let's go back to our
classroom example and suppose
that--let's go back to the first
definition by going back to our
metaphor of the class.
So you guys are all ants,
and suppose that every student
in the class is playing Ŝ.
You're all playing Ŝ
and suppose it's the case that
in fact the payoff of Ŝ
against Ŝ
is bigger than the payoff of
Ŝ against S',
and suppose that a mutation
arises, sorry Rahul here we go
again.
So as the mutation arises,
here's Rahul our mutation,
and he's going to be randomly
matched against one of you guys.
So let's compare Rahul's payoff
against this gentleman's payoff.
Stand up a second.
Your name is?
Student: Pat.
Professor Ben Polak:
Pat, all right.
So Pat is our typical Ŝ
incumbent ant,
doesn't look like an ant but
never mind, stretch your
imagination a bit.
Most of the time what's
happening?
Most of the time Pat is being
matched against one of the rest
of you, and when he's matched
against one of the rest of you,
he's getting the payoff Ŝ
against Ŝ,
which is U(Ŝ,Ŝ),
that's what he's getting most
of the time.
Every now and then he's meeting
a mutant.
Okay fine, so every now and
then he's getting a slightly
different payoff,
but most of the time he's
getting a payoff which is
U(Ŝ,Ŝ).
What about Rahul?
So Rahul, okay every now and
then he's going to be lucky and
meet another T.A.,
but most of the time,
almost all the time he's being
matched against one of you,
for example he's matched
against Pat.
When he's matched against Pat,
his payoff is U(Ŝ,S')
which is lower.
That right?
So Pat's payoff almost all the
time is U(Ŝ,Ŝ) and
Rahul's payoff almost all the
time is U(Ŝ,S').
But our assumption is
U(Ŝ,S') is lower,
so Rahul's going to die out.
So in this case,
Rahul dies out because most of
the time he's playing an
incumbent and just doing
horribly.
Everyone convinced by that?
So in this case,
the mutant dies out.
So the mutant dies out because
she or he meets Ŝ
often.
The mutant meets the incumbent
often and just does horribly
against the incumbent.
That's the first case,
that's case one and case two
is, it could be the case that in
fact Rahul does pretty well
against the incumbents,
but unfortunately for Rahul,
it could be the case,
sorry, but in that case
according to Definition B,
Rahul doesn't do so well
against other T.A.'s.
So this is case two,
case one was Rahul just gets
beaten up whenever he meets one
of you,
sorry Rahul you are getting
beaten up a lot here,
but Rahul gets beaten up when
he meets one of you,
and here's the case where Rahul
is doing fine against you,
but he does horribly against
incumbents,
so that's the harder case.
Let's talk through that case.
So back up again,
sorry Rahul you have to get up
again, so once again you guys
are all playing Ŝ's,
there's a mutation of Rahul's
playing S', and let's get Pat up
again.
So when Pat meets one of you
guys, so let's pick out one of
you guys, so let me pick out,
sorry your name is?
Student: Christine.
Professor Ben Polak:
Christine.
So when Pat meets Christine,
which is most of the time,
he does okay and when Rahul
meets Christine which happens
most of the time,
he does exactly the same.
So if you just compared them in
their random matches against
Christine all the rest of you,
they're the same.
But every now and then instead,
every ε
of the time,
rarely, Rahul is going to meet
Jake,
Jake's writing,
he's going to meet Kaj,
stand up a second and on those
occasions let's see what
happens.
So when Pat meets Kaj he does
pretty well, and he gets some
big bonanza, he gets a much
bigger payoff than when Rahul
meets Kaj,
they just do horribly against
each other.
The fact that they do horribly
against each other causes them
to die out.
So let's just talk this through.
There were two ways in which
Rahul could die out.
One is he dies out because he
does horribly against you and
the second way he can die out is
if he does equally well against
you as you do against yourself,
but he does horribly when he
meets the other T.A.'s.
In either case,
you guys are evolutionarily
stable and Rahul is in trouble.
Was that convincing enough an
argument?
There's a formal proof in the
handout but this will be enough
to get us started.
So in this case,
the mutant does okay against
Ŝ but gets clobbered,
does badly let's say against
S'.
So mutants that are going to
die out are those that do badly
against incumbents or do badly
against themselves.
In either case Ŝ
will be evolutionarily stable.
Now next time I want to take
this further in two directions.
I want to see what happens
about ES in more complicated
games, for example,
in cooperation games and we're
going to see that evolution
doesn't do great in cooperation
games.
We'll also, if we have time,
going to look at sexual
reproduction,
which is probably what you guys
are all interested in anyway.
I'll see you all on Monday.